I'm mathematical biologist here at Harvard
and before I begin my talk
I would like to tell you what a mathematical biologist is.
And it's best explained with a short story.
So there is a shepherd and a flock of sheep
and a man comes by it says:
"If I guess the correct number of sheep in your flock
can I have one?"
And the shepherd says: "OK, try it."
So the man looks and says: "83."
And the shepherd is completely amazed,
because it is right number.
So the man picks up a sheep and wants to walk away.
The shepherd says:
"Hang on. If I guess you profession
can I have my sheep back?"
"OK, try it."
"You must be a mathematical biologist."
"How did you know?"
"Because you picked up my dog!"
So in my field it's important to get the numbers right.
And today I'm talking about the evolution of cooperation.
Which is a very big topic
because Darwinian evolution based on natural selection,
and natural selection is a struggling for competition.
And in such a struggling the question would be:
"Why would we ever help anybody else?
Why should I reduce my own fitness, so to say,
to increase the fitness of somebody else?"
And that's a problem of evolution of cooperation.
So in the atomic interaction here
we have two people, say, or two cells, you know...
but let's talk about people here.
And one is a donor, and the other is a recipient.
Donor pays a cost.
And the recipient gets a benefit.
Cost and benefit are measured in reproductive success.
And reproduction can be genetic or cultural.
So we use the same framework to describe, say,
people learning how to behave without genetic reproduction,
we talk about cultural evolution here.
So if we have this framework
and if both people have to make a choice simultaneously
between cooperation and defection,
we get a very famous game.
It's a game in sence of game theory,
a field of mathematics that was invented by John von Neumann.
And so what you see here is that my choice and your choice.
And that what is written in a red
is what you would get if these were the outcomes.
So you have to look at this payoff matrix
and now you have to decide for an action.
Either to cooperate or to defect.
And I will also decide between cooperation and defection
so we will play the game simultaniously.
So please look at the matrix and make a choice.
Who wants to cooperate with me? Raise your hand.
Who wants to defect?
Very few defectors so some people...
many people haven't actually decided
so I should say that it is not an optional game.
In game theory we also have optional games
with that a third column which means "do nothing."
But this is not...
the prisoner's dillema,
you have to make a choice essentially.
So this is how you should think about it.
You don't know what I will do.
Let's assume I cooperate.
If I cooperate you have a choice between 'b - c' and 'b'.
So 'b' is greater than 'b - c'
because 'b' greater than 'c' greater than 0.
So if I cooperate you want to defect.
If I defect you have a choice between '-c' and 0.
So 0 is greater than '-c', so if I defect
you also want to defect.
Therefore, no matter what I might to be doing
it is better for you to defect.
And now if I analyse the game in a same way
we both end up with defection, we both get 0 points.
And that be very disappointed
because over there we would have had 'b - c' points
had we both cooperated.
And that precisely why it's called a dilemma.
So the dilemma is that there is incentive to defect,
but two cooperators are better than two defectors.
For the group it is better to cooperate
but for the individual there is always a temptation to defect.
And that's the problem here.
What I gave you it's so-called rational analysis
that is offered by game theorists and economists
to say that you cannot cooperate in a prisoners dilemma
as written here.
But we have seen that people cooperated.
It is also pointed out in experiments.
So the question is: "Why do people cooperate?"
I should say that as biologists
we analyse the games slightly differently,
we don't need the concept of rationality.
What I gave you was this rational analysis
and a rational player is defined in the game theory sence
as somebody who realizes what a Nash equilibrium is
and placed in a Nash equilibrium.
But most experiments showed that people are not... rational.
So the interesting thing is
biologists don't make use of that concept
but come to the same conclusion.
So if we have a mixed population of cooperators and defectors
a defector always has a higher payoff than a cooperator.
So therefore, defection becomes more and more popular
because this is how you make money.
You make more and more money
until everybody is a defector and the system breaks down.
So here natural selection destroys cooperation,
opposes what would be good for the population
and leaves the population in state of just defection.
So therefore, natural selection needs help
to favor cooperation over defection.
And this help is something that I summarized in five mechanisms.
So there has been work on this over the last forty years
and there have been many hundreds
or thousands of papers actually written on this.
And I categorized these papers
as belong it to one of five mechanisms.
And these mechanisms are:
kin selection, direct reciprocity, indirect reciprocity,
spatial selection, group selection.
And for the purpose of this meeting here
I want to discuss direct and inderect reciprocity,
if I'll have time, a little bit about spatial selection.
I'm happy to take a questions about the other mechanisms also.
So direct reciprocity is the idea "I help you, you help me."
And this was written in the important paper
by Robert Trivers in 1971.
So direct reciprocity leads
to the so-called repeated prisoner's dilemma.
We'd play this game that we just played not once
but several times.
If we played several times
it is no longer the case that the best thing is just to defect.
Because if I defect with you in a first round
that might upset you
and than you will never cooperate with me again, kind of.
But if I cooperate with you,
it is costly for me,
but it might lead you to cooperate with me.
So economists can prove a theorem called the Folk theorem
that it is possible to find cooperative Nash equilibrium
in the repeated prisoner's dilemma.
But the question is: "How does one play this game?"
And this question was asked in an imporant study
by a political scientist at the Ann Arbor University
in the late 70's, Robert Axelrod.
He said: "Let's have computer tournaments to playing this game."
So people send him computer strategies
to play the repeated prisoners dilemma
and he evaluate it then,
they beared each other up.
And then he announce the winner.
And the amazing thing is even though
many of the entries with smart strategies
that tried to predict, that tried to perceive...
in two consequentive tournaments
the simplest of all strategies won.
And the simplest strategy was a three-line computer program
sent by game theorist Anatol Rapaport and it says...
it's 'tit-for-tat'.
So I start with cooperation
and then I do whetever you did last round.
So without maybe...
without you ever noticed that you are playing yourself.
You are playing youself once removed
because I do exactly what you did last time.
And that strategy... at that time was considered
kind of a world champion in the prisoner's dilemma,
but it has a problem.
It has a following problem:
if two 'tit-for-tat' players play against each other
and there is a mistake...
One by accident defects the other one will hit back.
And this endless cycle of retaliation destroys cooperation.
So 'tit-for-tat' is unforgiving.
But to do well in a world with errors,
which was not in Axelrod's tournament,
but if you want to think about a realistic world
where people make mistakes,
you need a mechanism for forgiveness.
And 'tit-for-tat' doesn't do that.
So in my Ph.D. thesis I had natural selection
run a tournament on the computer
and then mathematical analisys
and do analyze what is happening
if we put it in the context where errors are always occuring
and not where we play arbitrary strategies sent by people
but natural selection chooses in spaces of strategies.
So I start with a random assemble of strategies.
The first thing that you get is "always defect".
So if people play randomly the best thing is to defect.
But fortunately for my Ph.D. thesis it wasn't over here.
Something interesting happened.
Tit-for-tat came in.
And you can actually prove that 'tit-for-tat'
is a very good catalyst for the emergence of cooperation.
It is a harsh vitaliator which you need
when almost everybody's defecting
to get some small cluster of cooperation going.
But amazingly
'tit-for-tat' was imediately replaced by another strategy.
And that other strategy was 'generous tit-for-tat'...
there's a formatting problem here.
So 'generous tit-for-tat' replaced 'tit-for-tat' immediately.
And what is 'generous tit-for-tat'?
If you cooperate I will always cooperate,
but if you defect
I will still cooperate with a certain probability.
And that also a recipe how to save many marriages.
In a kitchen counter at home you have dice.
You know, you roll dice
and then you decide whether to forgive or not.
And that would be a stable, kind of...
because you need a probabilistic strategy,
because a deterministic strategy could be exploited.
So this is a mathematical model
for the evolution of forgiveness.
But the interesting thing that happened next is
if everybody here plays 'generous tit-for-tat'
and I'd play 'always cooperate'
I have no disadvantage because everybody is nice
and I do never ever retaliate, you know,
but that doesn't matter because nobody exploits me.
So this is nowdays called in biology "random drift".
I mean neutral mutant.
But there is no pressure for this...
'generous tit-for-tat' like strategy to be maintained
random drift eliminates it to brings it "always cooperate."
It's like birds on an island without predators
loose their ability to fly.
A biological trait has to be under selection pressure
to be maintained.
So we drift to "always cooperate".
But you can guess what happens next.
You invite the invasion of "always defectors".
And we have a simple mathematical model of human history
and people have written books on such oscillations
between war and peace.
But the interesting thing in all my work
on evolution of cooperation over the last 20 years,
I've always find oscillations.
Cooperation is never stable.
There is no stable equilibrium.
How much cooperation you get in the system
depends completely how long you can hold it
and how quickly you can rebuild it
after it has been destroyed.
And that what you need in human society.
You need structures that rebuild cooperation quickly
after it has been destroyed.
Because you can bet on it that it will be destroyed.
It will always be destroyed.
And this oscillations we also see
in the oscillations of the financial system, for example.
There is the simple rule
and I like simple mathematical results
of this direct reciprocity allows evolution of cooperation
if the probability of playing another round is greater
than cost to benefit ratio.
So the overall mathematics is complicated
but there are some simple rules occasionally emerging.
But let me go to indirect reciprocity
because maybe that's even more important
for the context of this meeting.
So this is a Vincent Van Gogh painting of the good Samaritan.
And we don't really know the motive
of the good Samaritan to help this person,
but presumanbly he was not thinking:
"What if it is the first round of repetated prisoner's dilemma
and I should better cooperate you."
Instead the good Samaritan helps
and maybe the good Samaritan thinks:
"I help you, somebody will help me.
You know, if I'm in such a situation,
somebody might help me."
So how do we get indirect reciprocity to work?
If you can assign reputation to the players...
So here player A helps B and that the reputation of A increases.
Where A does not helped B and the reputation of A decreases.
So then you need natural selection to choose strategies
who based the decision to help on the reputation of others.
So here we need mechanisms that assign reputation.
And a web is perfect in doing such things,
this reputation mechanisms come in Ebay auctions
and in buyng and selling relationships.
So there was... this was a theory
that I've worked out with Karl Sigmund in the late 90's.
And experimental confirmation was published in 2000
where people did experiments with students
sitting in front of computers
and they find that people help whose who help others
and helpful people have a higher payoff in the end.
What you need for indirect reciprocity is gossip.
So people... there is some action going on between two people,
others observe it.
And then gossip spreads in the population.
And empirical observations such as
that humans are obsessed with gossip,
we are talking about others,
we are talking with others about others.
So people have done experiments in British trains
going up and down listening to what people are talking about.
I don't know if that is kind of legal, you know,
but 60% of this topics
were about inderect reciprocity in the certain sence.
So the very interesting thing is
for perfect mechanism of indirect reciprocity
you need human language.
So the human history you could eye this was the selection pressure
that led to social intelligence and to human language,
because you need to understand
who does what to whom in the social network
and you need to be able to talk about it.
My friend David Haig at Harvard said beautifully:
"For direct reciprocity you need a face.
And for indirect reciprocity you need a name."
So there is a lot in our brain that is just there
to recognize faces and reading actions into faces
and try to understand what people might be doing,
but that's not enough to indirect reciprocity.
For indirect reciprocity you need to be able to talk about others.
And that's seems to be typically human characteristic.
Again there is the simple rule here
and this is that natural selection
can favor cooperation by indirect reciprocity
if the probability to know someone's reputation
exceeds the cost to benefit ratio.
So you need mechanisms
such that interations are not completely anonymous.
If these actions are completely anonymous
you run into a problem.
But you also run into second problem
and this is that assigment of reputation
so to say the gossip itself has to be a game
that has to be conducted honestly.
So this is on the higher level a cooperation/defection problem.
Which is really studied.
Almost over...
So then spatial selection is just the idea
that neighbors help each other.
So you get cooperation emerging if cooperators can form clusters.
And then clusters of cooperators can prevail against defectors.
And this is something we study on graphs.
And we have studied this on all sorts of networks.
A random regular graphs, random graphs, scale-free networks.
And to our great surprise
we've found a beautiful simple mathematical rule
that these graphs selection favors cooperation
if the benefit to costs ratio is greater
than the average number of neighbors.
So this spatial selection works
if you have a few close friends.
If you interact loosely with a very large number of people
that is much harder for that mechanism to work.
Something else with this evolutionary set theory
where people belong to sets.
They interact with others in the sets
and they join successful sets.
And that is also something that leads
to the right spatial stucturing
that can be a powerful mechanism for cooperators
to find each other in sets.
So you hear about groups that work well together
and you want to join that group.
And that can be a powerful mechanism.
So there five mechanisms.
I've discussed three of them.
And there are simple rules for all five of them.
And these are the cooperators in my group here at Harvard.
And recently I wrote a book called "Super cooperators"
where I summarized some of these ideas.
Thank you very much.
Question for Martin while Nicolas is setting up the slides.
But with the spatial selection
one way of thinking about that there is...
I think it's actually...
I think it's done how it's work
which was listen to gossip on trains.
And that brings in a whole other issue around privacy
which is the notion of networks
and our technologies making it possible for us
to have much larger networks of stronger ties.
So when you said that a...
that a larger networks didn't have the same level of cooperation
with that because they were larger
or because they were weakly connected?
So what we call a "well-mixed population" is a complete graph
where everybody interacts with everybody else equally strongly.
And this does not provide selection pressure for cooperation.
What you want is that you have a few connections
with people and these are cooperators.
But there is a very interesting tradeoff,
because I can achieve it by saying I only have one friend
and we will cooperate and we can never be exploited.
But then it there somebody else showing up, you know,
I could increase my overall income
by also making this connection.
So we build a bigger network.
And what we found in the recent study
is that the network as it becomes bigger and bigger,
generates more and more wealth,
but becomes more and more vulnerable
to the exploitation of defectors.
And at the point where defectors can destroy it
you have the largest wealth.
So there is a tradeoff between wealth and stability.